merci monsieur le ministre
de votre présence avec nos excuses pour
le retard
c'est donc pour laquelle je ferai court
donc vous venez dans le cadre de
l'organisation de la police judiciaire
notamment de rapporteurs sont ici nous
sommes probablement les derniers à ne
positionner sur ce sujet puisque la
cervelationale a déposé un rapport que
je qualifierais peut-être de bicéphale
le chez nous le commission nous a fait
économiques par économie finance des
finances pardon par l'intermédiaire de
Monsieur Dominati a également commis un
rapport naturellement sont arrivés et
les rapports de l'inspection générale de
mistration d'inspection générale de la
justice ainsi que de l'IGPN ce qui fait
que nous auditionnons après
reconnaissance de l'ensemble de ces
éléments et pour notre part nous
rendrons notre rapport sur le cas les
rapporteurs feront état de leurs travaux
au tout début du mois de mars juste
après la suspension voilà nous sommes
déjà trop longs je vais vous laisser la
parole pour recueillir votre point de
vue et puis nos rapporteurs et les
collègues souhaiteront pourront
naturellement s'exprimer comme il est
d'usage on me dit d'un point de vue
pratique qu'il y aurait peut-être des
photographes
mais on les a pas vu donc
l'affaire est réglée
et nous sommes retransmis également mais
les photographes ne sont pas là donc
voilà c'est fait très bien chez le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur rapporteur madame monsieur est
très heureux de passer cette partie de
Saint-Valentin avec vous
et de parler d'un dossier très important
qui
je crois bien été
échangé on va dire ça comme ça alors du
débat sénatorial en commission en
audition et puis évidemment en séance
puisque
cette réforme de la police nationale et
moi je pense qu'il faut d'abord insister
sur le fait que c'est la réforme de la
police nationale et pas simplement la
réforme de la police judiciaire comme on
le lit est trop improprement sinon on ne
comprend pas très bien ce que veut faire
le gouvernement a été modifié si je veux
dire
enrichi puis finalement on trouve un
compromis avec le gouvernement par le
travail du Sénat je vois ça rapporte de
bras c'est le rapporteur Hervé qui ont
évidemment beaucoup contribué à ça pour
trouver une écriture je crois consensuel
qui permettait à la fois de mettre un
certain nombre de bornes qui nous
semblait évidente mais qu'on a rappelé
dans le marbre de la loi et qui par
ailleurs faisait naître notamment les
rendez-vous d'aujourd'hui puisque on
s'est engagé
publier les rapports ce que j'ai fait je
crois que chez qu'elle a vu le jour même
avec le garde des sceaux que ce rapport
de l'Inspection générale de la justice
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale l'inspection générale
administration ont commis évidemment
évoquer devant les commissions quand
j'étais engagé monsieur le Président à
dire ce qu'en fait le gouvernement
le Conseil constitutionnel d'ailleurs
n'a pas eu à redire grand-chose sur la
loi que j'ai l'honneur de porter avec
votre travail votre concours et
d'ailleurs à valider la réforme de la
police nationale il n'y a pas mis de
réserve particulière notamment sur la
question importante qui a évoqué a été
évoqué par de nombreux parlementaires
sur la séparation des pouvoirs et le
lien qu'il y a entre l'autorité
judiciaire et pouvoir exécutif je n'y
reviens pas je pense que l'essentiel
puisque vous rapporteur travail à la
finalisation j'imagine de leur rapport
et que l'audition il y a quasiment
chlore quasiment le cycle d'audition qui
ont pu mener l'important est sans doute
l'échange que je peux avoir avec eux et
avec l'ensemble des dessinateurs je
voudrais peut-être dire trois à trois
choses très rapides pour dire où on en
est nous du point de vue du ministère de
l'Intérieur d'abord conformément à mon
engagement que j'ai pris devant la Haute
Assemblée devant l'Assemblée nationale
je ne ferai rien
dans la réforme de la police nationale
puisqu'il s'agit intégralement d'une
réforme qui relève soit de mon pouvoir
réglementaire
soit d'un fonctionnement on va dire
quotidien des services de police tant
que les trois rapports ne sont pas
rendus et tant que je n'en aurai pas
étudié les conclusions bien évidemment 2
sur 3 donc été rendus je reviens
peut-être rapidement sur le rapport des
inspections du gouvernement mais aussi
sur le rapport en effet bicéphale de
l'Assemblée nationale commis par exemple
je prends le premier point le rapport du
gouvernement
comme celui de l'Assemblée nationale
peut-être comme celui du Sénat je ne
sais pas en tout cas dans les deux
rapports y compris d'ailleurs par
Monsieur Bernal ici celui même ce qui
est à souligné pour notre part
personne ne remet en cause de bien
fonder de il faut faire quelque chose
dans la police nationale qui travaille
en silo depuis extrêmement longtemps et
qui peut-être
mériterait d'être modernisé et dans la
police nationale évidemment
régulièrement dans la filière judiciaire
en particulier devant le nombre
d'enquêtes très important et devant
aussi la mutation de la délinquance et
la comité entre pays donc je crois qu'on
est à peu près d'accord si on constate
je ne sais pas ce que les rapporteurs
mais il s'agit pas de ne rien faire rien
faire serait que laisser continuer une
forme de délinquance des taux
d'élucidation qui ne seraient pas au
rendez-vous désespéré la filière
judiciaire et donc toute la police
nationale et puis surtout ne pas
s'adapter au monde moderne qui est le
nôtre qui va grandissant le cyber
stupéfiant les messagers cryptés nous
connaissons tous ceux-là le deuxième
point sur lequel on semble à peu près
d'accord le rapport d'un semestational
comme celui des inspections c'est que
l'idée de créer une filière judiciaire
puisqu'elle n'existe pas en tant que tel
aujourd'hui pareil d'une bonne idée y
compris d'ailleurs souligné par Monsieur
bernadisse et donc je m'en félicite
c'est le ne évidemment de l'inquiétude
que l'on peut avoir et qui est légitime
de la part notamment d'un certain nombre
d'agents de la police judiciaire
actuellement je reviendrai
je vais rester peut-être désormais sur
le rapport de des inspections puisque je
n'ai pas eu encore l'honneur d'exprimer
devant la semaine nationale et j'en
dirai évidemment rapporteur ce que j'en
pense bien sûr de leur conclusion j'ai
l'occasion de dire avec le garde des
sceaux que nous prendrions l'intégralité
des remarques et des préconisations des
inspections au sens large notamment de
mériteraient particulièrement vu et que
je n'avais pas imaginé dans un premier
temps d'abord pour bien montrer qu'il
s'agit d'une filière judiciaire et que
l'autorité judiciaire a évidemment
absolument accès aux autorités de police
qui sont sous ce sont d'autorité
l'évaluation de ces futurs direction
départementale de la police nationale se
fera à la fois par le préfet le
directeur départemental de la police
nationale mais aussi par le procureur de
la République je pense que ça c'est une
innovation proposée notamment par
l'Inspection générale la justice qui me
paraît frapper du coin du bon sens et
qui permet de souligner de montrer qu'il
y a évidemment aucun problème notamment
sur le fameux article 12 qui prévoit la
saisie du service et de la liberté du
service enquêteur et puis le deuxième
point sur lequel moi je voudrais avoir
un oeil un œil particulier c'est
notamment la question qui a été faite de
décentralisation d'un certain nombre de
décision on pense évidemment à des
choses aussi pratiques que des frais de
mission le pouvoir judiciaire peut avoir
peur que ce soit un peu trop centralisé
et surtout de l'action qui est qui est
menée par la police judiciaire je pense
que les propositions de décentralisation
proposées par le rapport seront
également très très bonne chose dans la
réflexion alors en attendant peut-être
le rapport du Sénat et vous dire
exactement ce qu'on ce que nous ferons
je vais vous donner quelques dates
peut-être des futurs échéances à partir
de la semaine prochaine je recevrai
l'intégralité des organisations
syndicales de la police nationale des
gardiens de la paix jusqu'au commissaire
de police en passant par le personnel
administratif technique et scientifique
dans des discussions bilatérales pour
les entendre sur la réforme de la police
nationale et justement sur cette
question et les rapports auront été je
crois publiés d'ici là y compris ceux du
Sénat et je j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
que le calendrier serait celui de
l'année 2023 pour la pour la réforme je
prendrai donc après cette consultation
syndicale à Saint-Ouen de décision qui
tira les conclusions soit des rapports
des assemblées mais aussi des
propositions des syndicats pour avoir au
mois de avril prochain la désignation
des directeurs zonaux puisque l'idée
c'est de faire des directions par zone
unique de la police nationale et puis
ensuite après entre la fin de l'été et
après la communion de rugby pour pas
désorganiser évidemment la police
nationale dans ce grand événement
deux types de nominations de Direction
Départementale
ceux qui ont une quarantaine de
départements ne sont pas concernés par
les grands événements sportifs qui
pourraient faire l'objet d'une première
nomination fin août début septembre et
puis ceux qui sont par les grands
événements sportifs pour pas les gêner
dans l'organisation de faire après la
colonne de rugby donc plutôt au mois
d'octobre ce qui fait que l'année 2023 à
la fin d'année 2023 nous serions en
ordre de marche nous aurions les
directeurs par filière de la police
nationale les directeurs zones
nationales et directeurs départementaux
de la police nationale étant entendu je
le dire ici qu'il s'agit pas de prendre
les directeurs de la sécurité publique
et de faire des recettes c'est pas comme
ça que ça a fonctionné nous allons
mettre des patrons de PJ directeur zono
de la police nationale patron de la PAF
directeur national de la police
nationale il s'agit bien évidemment que
chacun
chacune des anciennes directions
puissent être bien représentés dans
l'ensemble évidemment de ces de ces
nominations j'ai proposé par souci à la
fois d'apaisement et de continuité que
dans un premier temps et en attendant
les rapports de vos rapporteurs que les
directeurs actuels centraux de la PJ de
la voie publique de la PAF DRT et de ce
qu'on appelle la DRC Pen c'est à dire le
soutien la police nationale soit donné
préfigurateurs donc l'information
importante c'est juste dire c'est que la
DCPJ actu actuelle la direction centrale
la préjudiciaire actuelle monsieur
bonnet et le préfigurateur de la police
judiciaire de demain est-ce qu'il veut
donc dire qu'il s'agit évidemment de
réaffirmer qu'il y a bien une direction
de la police judiciaire et qui aura
toujours une préjudiciaire en France
bien évidemment voilà ce que je voulais
dire quelques mots monsieur le monsieur
le Président en vous disant que c'est la
forme très importante je crois qu'elle a
pas vraiment d'équivalent sans de payer
de mots dans l'administration que je
dirige on peut dire qu'il y a eu deux
très grandes réformes dans la police
nationale dans son organisation ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas eu ici ou là
des améliorations bien sûr la réforme
des années 60 quand le général de Gaulle
a pris un nouveau statut de la police
nationale
1964 nous sommes le deal de mémoire et
puis la réforme de 1995 qui est même
faisait suite à la réforme avortée
95 c'est là où on a décidé de fusionner
les inspecteurs de police peut-être
qu'on les voyait dans les films
précédents
spécialistes dans les enquêtes avec la
voix publique et on a fait un seul corps
de police certains des regrettent cette
réforme qui aurait un peu éloigné un
certain nombre de nos policiers de de
des habitants mais voilà c'est la
réforme Pasqua qui faisait suite à
d'autres réformes précédentes avec
beaucoup de pairs mais on peut dire sur
ce pays de mots que depuis 40 ans il y a
pas eu de réformes dans la police
nationale contrairement à ce qui s'est
passé dans la gendarmerie ou dans
l'armée si on prend un certain nombre
d'autres exemples et au moins depuis les
années 60 si on évoque la police
nationale en tant qu'administration
voilà en quelques mots donc il est
normal que une réforme aussi compliqué
aussi forte qui touche les 200 000
agents de la police nationale fasse
naître des interrogations je les entends
je les écoute je veux les rassurer une
nouvelle fois et j'espère que le travail
que vous ferez nous aidera évidemment à
être avoir une police nationale plus
efficace en entendant les questions des
agents qui courageusement travaillent à
protection des Français
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à nos rapporteur et le monsieur Jérôme
dur merci monsieur le Président je vais
commencer par cette audition et première
question
pour ce qui me concerne au ministre en
lui donnant qui tue de la parole donnée
puisque à ce stade tous les rendez-vous
que nous avions étaient honorés on s'est
tenu à ce plan de charge donc pour notre
travail parlementaire c'est quand même
assez confortable de pouvoir avoir ces
points d'étape dire aussi que le rapport
de l'Assemblée nationale a été bicéphale
alors nous avons aussi Saint-Valentin
aujourd'hui de noms de visages mais à ce
stade ce sera sans doute de visage et un
seul discours pour le rapport final
enfin si tout se passe bien jusque là
avec ma Cora porter
terminer ce très court préambule en
disant que effectivement ce qu'on peut
observer des des expressions des
rapports et des écrits que nous avons pu
lire la question de l'acceptation des
constats c'est généralisé sur
l'évolution de la criminalité sur les
questions posées aux limites de
l'organisation actuelle que ce soit en
termes d'élucinations d'attractivité une
police en silo les questions d'unicité
de commandement finalement je pense que
c'est pas tout ça qui fera des bas en
revanche avec quelques questions qui se
posent à nous et qu'on essaiera de
régler dans la quinzaine de jours qui
nous séparent de la remise du rapport
final c'est une question de méthode
parfois le sentiment que ça a été un peu
fait cette réforme sans la police il
faudrait pas que ça se fasse contre elle
et puis c'est quelques questions de fond
la première tient
à la dichotomie entre l'autorité
hiérarchique et l'auto et l'autorité
fonctionnelle
c'est un des enjeux un des grands enjeux
de la réforme quelle définition vous
envisagez pour cette autorité
fonctionnelle et peut-être pouvez-vous
nous indiquer où en est l'élaborations
des doctrines nationales et la mise en
oeuvre des directions nationales même si
vous l'avez ce qui s'est tout à l'heure
deuxième question c'est
la question des moyens opérationnels
d'enquête au niveau zonal on a vu que le
rapport des inspections se prononçait
plutôt contre leur maintien serait
privilégié la possibilité de saisine des
services localisés sur un département
voisin éventuellement avec un une
extension temporaire du champ
territorial de compétences de services
alors on voit bien l'intérêt que ça peut
présenter pour des le traitement
d'affaires sensibles mais sur des
phénomènes dont les ravummifications
c'est endos d'aide d'un département
comment on fait travailler un niveau
régional voir interrégional et la
saisine du niveau national au-delà des
offices sera-t-elle toujours possible et
puis dernier point l'organisation de la
filière investigation au niveau de
chaque département
reproduira tel à ce stade et dans les
perspectives qui sont les vôtres
l'organisation en trois niveaux qui a
déjà été mise en place dans les
outre-mer voilà pour mes trois questions
merci Madame bellerault peut-être merci
alors moi je vais vous questionner
monsieur le ministre plus
particulièrement
par rapport aux audits qui ont été faits
et des conclusions qui ont pu être
rendus ou en tout cas les constats qui
ont pu être fait et notamment
en vue de l'ampleur des modifications
réglementaires qui peut donner une que
peut donner lieu cette réforme
aussi bien aussi des modifications
numériques immobilières je voudrais
juste rappeler ce qu'a pu dire votre
inspection les trois inspecteurs
généraux
concernant par exemple les problèmes
numériques où ils disent clairement ce
qui ont été rencontrés ce sont révélés
être un frein majeur
il disait exactement ensuite que
concernant les problématiques numériques
il en résultera une période transitoire
durant laquelle le fonctionnement
s'effectuera en mode dégradé voir avec
l'interruption temporaire de certains
accès dans un contexte
de fonctionnement des outils numériques
qui suscitent de vivre critiques la
manœuvre numérique fait peser un risque
spécifique sur la réussite initiale de
la réforme
il parle également de l'immobilier où
ils disent que c'est un projet très
ambitieux et qu'il y a besoin de
regroupement de cette immobilier assez
rapidement pour que ça soit et ça nous
l'avons entendu dans nos auditions le
fait que bon c'est un moyen constant en
effet ça c'est une chose mais que il
soit sur des sites différents ne permet
pas forcément une bonne efficience du
dispositif alors ma question est compte
tenue donc de ces peut-être comment
dirais-je crainte j'aimerais savoir le
calendrier est-ce qu'il vous paraît
vraiment réalisable je parle pas aussi
de la formation de cddpn qui est très
importante vous l'avez dit vous avez
entièrement raison et la qualité du ddpn
évidemment une restera la qualité de la
réussite de cette réforme une formation
ça prend du temps c'est moyen
réglementaires cette mise en œuvre aussi
bien donc je d'un point de vue numérique
immobilier c'est long aussi allant donc
est-ce que vous pour vous le calendrier
vous paraît vraiment réalisable et
est-ce que cette généralisation j'ai
entendu que vous parliez de la fin de
cette année mais est-ce que une
généralisation avant l'échéance des Jeux
Olympiques et crédibles et j'aimerais
également vous questionner sur les
stocks alors là on a vu nous en tout cas
moi j'ai découvert plus qu'une montagne
de stock c'est c'est assez
impressionnant le stock qui a été mis en
lumière à l'occasion des constatations
sur la réforme et vous les connaissez
beaucoup mieux que que moi et que nous
mais ça a été vraiment stupéfiant c'est
évidemment un enjeu majeur qui peut
obérer le bon fonctionnement de la
justice et puis plus généralement de la
société dans les années à venir
c'est une insatisfaction que peuvent
avoir nos concitoyens lorsqu'ils n'ont
pas eu de réponse à leur plaintes le
rapport des inspections annonce qu'une
mission d'inspection a été lancée sur ce
sujet en décembre 2022
quels sont les objectifs qui sont
assignés à cette mission et quelle
solution pour être mise en oeuvre pour
résorber ces stocks je j'entends que la
réorganisation et la réforme proposée
n'avait pas pour objet de réserver ses
stocks mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que nous avons découvert des milliers et
des milliers et des milliers de dossiers
qui ne sont pas qui n'ont pas été
traités merci beaucoup
le président peut-être
ici ou là peut-être la question générale
de la méthode on veut tous des erreurs
très certainement et
on pourrait davantage expliciter ce
qu'on de faire la difficulté quand même
c'est qu'on voit bien
que
bouscule beaucoup de choses en faisant
la réforme de la police nationale et que
un certain nombre d'incompréhensions
peut être bien sûr du fait de
l'administration et du ministre
évidemment en chef de cette
administration mais il ne faut pas
sous-estimer aussi le bon très différent
que l'on fait faire à la police
nationale certains peuvent le prendre
contre eux c'est absolument pas le cas
mais il est évident qu'on leur demande
une accélération de modernisation et de
changement de comportement qui aurait pu
être fait auparavant et qui n'a pas été
fait et que devant les difficultés la
complexité de la délinquance mais aussi
parce que vous évoquez tout à l'heure
sur les divers problèmes que nous allons
rencontrer les grands événements
sportifs la grande communauté qui est
devant nous c'est sûr que c'est une une
réforme qui ne se fait pas par étape et
qui se fait
off si je sers du coup ça rend les
choses plus complexes le grand avantage
que nous avons ça répond à la fois votre
question ce numérique et sur
l'immobilier c'est qu'on y a des moyens
très importants immobiliers numériques
et formation donc
nous avons prévu dans la Love Me des
moyens pour accompagner l'immobilier
pour accompagner l'information pour
accompagner le numérique
détailler chacun des sujets que vous
évoquez même la rapporteur et je pense
qu'une grande partie des ressources
syndicales et des policiers le voient
quand même c'est à dire que c'est à la
fois une vraie forme qui change la façon
de fonctionner la police par exemple qui
met des moyens pour accompagner ce
changement indépendamment des habitudes
et parfois un peu il faut bien le dire
aussi de la nostalgie avec des maisons
qu'on est très grosse
identité la préjudiciaire c'est une
maison chacun sait qui a une grosse
identité on la comprend très bien
d'ailleurs et qu'il faut accompagner
disparaît pas elle va se moderniser si
j'ose dire à la même hauteur aussi c'est
une comparaison à peu prétentieuse mais
mais que lorsque Clémenceau a créé les
brigades du tir il a fait un constat
j'ai déjà dit dans l'hémicycle que la
criminalité organisée fallait donc
organiser la police nationale bon
auparavant la plupart de la police était
municipale vous le savez c'est l'objet
du travail de Clemenceau qui est
d'ailleurs à l'époque il y avait des
grèves et des contestations de la
réforme de Clemenceau comme quoi c'est
des forces se répètent sur la planète
peut-être sur la question des des
difficultés
évoqué par le rapport en tout cas par
rapport des inspections du ministère
d'intérêt de la justice on est en
désaccord sur un point sur notamment la
question de la probité je sais pas si
vous rappelez de ce débat qui consistait
effectivement dire quand il y a des
enquêtes qui ont de la probité des élus
ou des chefs d'entreprise raison vu
faire des gens connus dans un
département le fait qu'il y a un
directeur unique de la police nationale
avec un lien particulier avec le préfet
le fait qu'ils sortent voilà de on
pourrait imaginer moi je pense que c'est
un fantasme enfin j'essaie de comprendre
aussi des peurs qui se qui se
matérialisent notamment de la part des
magistrats que ben voilà la PJ était un
petit peu à part souvent la police de
sécurité publique c'est plutôt la
sécurité publique à contact avec le
préfet des élus là le fait qu'un
directeur unique va s'occuper des deux
peut-être qu'il peut renseigner comme
dans un film de Chabrol entre le notaire
et le et le cousin évêque qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans la grande ville de la
préfecture bon je crois pas que les
préfets fasse ça toute la journée mais
imaginons donc on a on a fait un choix
ensemble on avait refait mettre dans le
texte de loi qu'on allait dépayser
l'affaire bon là il y a deux manières de
la dépayser nous on a proposé la montée
au niveau zonal
ce soit pas la direction locale qui la
traite mais une direction zonale et la
rapport d'inspection notamment proposé
par le l'inspecteur général de justice
qui s'occupait elle dit bah plutôt faire
la direction
frontalière c'est-à-dire le département
d'à côté alors pourquoi parce qu'il
partait du principe que quand il faut
faire des perquisitions lorsqu'il faut
faire ça tombe d'actes qui sont parfois
très simple en fait imaginons un élu qui
soupçon de corruption particulier ou
note de frais pour j'en sais rien bon
faut faire des perquises et ça on va pas
demander au type de de l'île d'aller
dans l'Oise c'est trop loin alors qu'on
aurait pu faire le type de la somme qui
vient dans l'Oise bon moi ce qui me ce
qui m'a ce qui m'interroge dans cette
proposition fait parmi ça la justice
c'est que je la trouve un peu
contradictoire imaginons ce serait un
peu absurde de penser que si le défaut
c'est dire qu'il est préfé parle que le
préfet de l'or ne va pas informer le
préfet de Seine-Maritime si jamais il y
a un élu qui le concernait qu'il le
connaît bien s'il parle il peut qui
parle dans la même région il se voit
dans la conférence de préfet ils discute
entre eux ils ont leur numéro de
téléphone donc le niveau zonal me
paraissait plus protecteur que le
département voisin bon voilà donc c'est
je pense qu'il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
challenge à cette proposition c'est pas
non plus la base de la réforme c'est un
détail qui est important mais évidemment
il faut il faut bien sûr on va voir ça
donc moi je partage une légère
divergence mais après tout tout
s'explique sur la saisie au niveau
national bien évidemment indépendamment
des offices il appartient au magistrat
de désigner le service de police qu'il
souhaite il y a même des moments où vous
savez bien les magistrats saisissent les
gendarmes plutôt que les policiers même
en zone police pour plein de raisons ou
qui qui décident de saisir à nos fils
telle enquête spécialisée et moi qui est
dirigé les services de police fiscale de
Bercy voilà le magistrat peut très bien
saisir la police fiscale qu'on avait mis
en place à Bercy puisque j'ai eu
l'honneur de la créer plutôt que la
brigade financière parce qu'il trouve
qu'il y a plus de spécialisation à la
brigade fiscale quand il s'agit des
sujets très très complexe ou de saisir
le service d'enquête douanière voilà
donc le magistrat a une très large
palette de services enquêteurs qui ne
relève pas tous mises à l'intérieur bien
évidemment donc bien évidemment au
niveau local qu'au niveau national le
fait de faire de la réforme n'oblige pas
les magistrats à un niveau de saisie
c'est à eux de connaître la saisie voire
la décisive pour ressaisir un autre un
autre service bien évidemment
les mois je pense que c'est très
intéressant histoire des trois niveaux
de de police judiciaire le 3 le 2 le 1
le 1 étant le spectre on va dire ça
comme ça c'est que ça permet d'avoir une
progression aussi des OPJ et l'un des
drames que nous avons dans la police
nationale c'est que le travail de PJ est
fatigant et il a pas des horaires comme
la sécurité publique qui lui permet
d'avoir un minimum je le dis comme ça
d'une vie de famille parce que la
sécurité publique aussi évidemment
connaît beaucoup de difficultés mais
enfin ils ont désormais un week-end sur
deux il travaille dans des horaires qui
sont un peu plus acceptable le PJ quand
il y a une enquête par manque d'ailleurs
de PJ dans un souvent dans un dans un
petit commissariat par exemple il doit
faire ça tout le temps donc du coup on
est fatigué on est pas très bien payé on
n'a pas toujours la réponse pénale qu'on
veut c'est complexe le processeur
numérique marche pas on voit pas très
bien donc on arrête voilà et c'est aussi
une sorte de découragement des EPG dans
notre pays et parce qu'en fait quand
vous êtes obligé au commissariat de
Tourcoing votre proversion de carrière
elle est assez limitée ou alors faut
vraiment partir très loin et donc il
faut emmener sa famille pour pouvoir
essayer d'avoir promotion pour devenir
chef de la brigade des familles ou chef
d'une brigade financière alors que si on
fait la direction départementale de la
police nationale on peut casser les EPG
par catégorie et les faire progresser à
l'intérieur même une direction
départementale et ça évite me
semble-t-il cet horizon un peu fermé
qu'on les EPG et qui dénaturent je
rappelle que la mode 5000 en France et
il y a une forme de motivation
évidemment leur donner davantage
je constate d'ailleurs que les rapports
en tout cas le rapport
du ministère de l'intérieur de la
justice comme le rapport enfin de ces
inspections dans ce national démontre
parce que c'est un peu l'objet quand
même de ces rapports que des dtpn en
outre-mer ont très bien fonctionné et
que les ddpn en métropole ont fonctionné
parfois très bien parfois moins bien
mais à chaque fois les rapports disent
oui mais attention comme c'est à droite
constant c'est difficile à savoir c'est
tout à fait vrai et on peut constater
tous ensemble que autorité judiciaire
comme policier gendarme ont tous
constaté que que ce soit en Guyane ou
nouvelle qui est le Mayotte ou aux
Antilles le DTP n'a apporté énormément
de choses et ces trois niveaux de DPJ
ont apporté énormément de
sur la doctrine elle serait publiée
avant l'été pardon de cette réponse de
Normand mais il y a le fait qu'on
attendait un peu quand même les rapports
des assemblées monsieur
sénateur c'est pas une insulte le
préciser je vois les sénateurs Normands
se rebeller
je vais pas vous faire une promesse de
gascon en vous disant que vous aurez
deux trides mais si vous les aurez vous
les aurez avant l'été bien évidemment je
les passerai au chaud monsieur le
Président mais on attendait aussi de
connaître vos conclusions pour pouvoir
adopter c'est doctrines sur les
questions évoquées bon autorité
hiérarchique fonctionnelle j'entends
votre question mais vous êtes trop
savant monsieur Center pour ne pas avoir
propre réponse c'est déjà un peu le cas
en fait l'autorité fonctionnelle
hiérarchique dans la police nationale
j'essaie d'expliquer au maire que je
rencontre qui veulent absolument avoir
des pouvoirs préjudiciaires c'est-à-dire
que vous le savez mieux que personne
désormais Conseil a dit si vous voulez
l'histoire de judiciaire vous donnerez
votre 10 à la police au procureur de la
République c'est exactement ce qui
m'arrive ce qui m'arrive c'est que moi
j'embauche votre nom à tous donc tous
les Français je les paye je peux
augmenter les primes je les habille je
les équipes sur quelques pouvoirs de
police très particulier que le public
j'ai évidemment un poids plus fort que
dans les enquêtes judiciaires mais dès
que ça relève de l'enquête judiciaire je
dirige pas la police nationale cet
après-midi voilà je une question d'un
député de la France insoumise qui a dit
mais est-ce que vous mettrez tous les
moyens pour arrêter la personne qui
agression d'agriculteur
ça dépend pas de moi puisque c'est sous
l'enquête bon donc en fait c'est du très
longtemps en fait que la police
nationale comme la gendarmerie agit en
autorité hiérarchique je suis le patron
de la police nationale au sens où je
nomme les gens mais je leur donne des
congés bon mais je ne suis pas
l'autorité fonctionnelle je ne dis pas
aux gens faites une enquête sur monsieur
X c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
dans un état de droit donc en fait
on réinvente quelque chose qui existe
depuis toujours dans la police nationale
peut-être qu'on le dit on le dit encore
davantage et on précise encore davantage
mais il est certain qu'elle est pour
fonction la police nationale auprès des
magistrats sans aucun doute je ne peux
pas donner de l'ordre à la police à la
police judiciaire
sur le numérique non mais vous êtes
parfaitement raison c'est assez moi je
veux dire
autant mis ça à l'intérieur est un
ministère formidable les femmes les
hommes qui la composent qui composent ce
mystère sont courageux travailleurs
implantés mais faut avouer qu'on a un
problème c'est que nous ne savons pas
faire des projets numériques voilà c'est
un c'est un fait j'ai été pendant trois
ans ministre des comptes publics j'ai le
bonheur de faire la poêle à source elle
a dématérialisation de vos impôts je
crois que c'est une administration qui
sait faire ce genre de projet et quand
le chat il vomisse à l'intérieur pour
plein de raisons que je pouvais vous
expliciter mais ça serait un peu long on
ne sait pas très bien les faire et ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent bon et ça c'est
très pas très efficient évidemment pour
pour le service public de la sécurité
mais en plus ça désespère Margaux qui
travaille dans le commissariat parce que
la difficulté c'est que parfois on
oblige aujourd'hui des gens à réimprimer
des procédures numériques où il y a
tellement d'entrées dans la procédure
numérique c'est vraiment été fait par
des gens qui ont jamais vu de procédure
a priori voilà c'est pas été imaginé que
le ministère de la Justice enfin
franchement rien n'était rien n'est
droit j'ai
changer une très grande partie des
choses on va changer chef de projet on a
mis beaucoup plus d'argent on a mis à la
tête de ces projets des gens qui ont une
certaine conception de la vie
informatique parce que l'un des premiers
pays nationales et je dirais je voudrais
dire un peu contre si vous me permettez
cette expression de la gendarmerie c'est
que comme il n'y avait jusqu'à présent
pas de formation scientifique dans la
police nationale pour conduire des
projets scientifiques c'était plus dur
le commissaire de police il est fait
pour plein de choses mais peut-être pas
pour diriger des grands projets
numériques parce que c'est un autre
métier voilà et donc d'ailleurs je suis
très heureux de croire que l'École
polytechnique désormais accepte les
quatre commissaires de police qui
sortent de cette école pour pouvoir
justement dans la police nationale avoir
des formations scientifiques comme on
les ont les gendarmes qui qui ont réussi
à faire à la fois des sens si rien des
polytechniciens des gens qui venaient
d'ailleurs et donc oui on a des
problèmes numériques très importants et
c'est très fort en fait elle va elle va
elle va les aider à aller mieux me
semble-t-il d'abord parce que en même
temps vous avez voté la loopy avec des
moyens supplémentaires mais aussi un
certain nombre de changements profonds
la plain en ligne et la visioplinte
c'est une transformation dès le début
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on a fait dans
procédure numérique jusqu'à présent en
fait c'était le monde papier qu'on
transformait en numérique et comme la
justice allait pas forcément suivie vu
la taille des tuyaux on réimprimé pour
la justice voilà alors que là le début
c'est dès le début on fait du numérique
a commencé par le dépôt de plainte et je
pense que ça changera énormément de
choses y compris dans les saisines fait
par les par les magistrats donc si
j'entends vos interrogations et ça des
agents en fait je crois qu'on repart un
peu from scratch sur deux grands projets
Scribe et rpppn on a aussi l'occasion
d'en reparler mais en fait ça ne marche
pas indépendamment de la réforme de la
police nationale et et nous faisons les
deux en même temps et ce sera une très
bonne chose sur l'immobilier oui
j'entends votre question d'agroupement
d'abord on a prévu beaucoup d'argent
dans 400 millions d'euros de mémoire par
an dans la loomie pour faire des projets
immobiliers y compris pour on avait
imaginé les ddpn c'est vrai vous avez
raison qui a besoin de regroupement mais
dans les faits il y a quand même déjà
beaucoup de mouvements qui sont faits
parce que les vrais coupants qui se
posent c'est dans les plus gros
départements on va dire ça on va dire ça
comme ça et moi non je ne suis pas du
tout inquiet sur le fait qu'on se donne
toute une année pour faire la réforme de
la police nationale donc moi je crois
que nous serons prêts pour descendre
2023 sans aucun problème après oui vous
avez raison on va mettre trois ans
quatre ans peut-être à prendre tous les
textes réglementaires il y a la 166 de
mémoire et ce sera pas fait pour les JO
mais c'est pas très grave c'est pas ça
le problème le problème c'est qu'on est
une police organisée évidemment pour
professeur 2023 objectivement je n'ai
pas d'inquiétude particulière sur son
organisation et sur sa formation sur les
stocks et j'en terminerai par là bon
c'est c'est pas propre à la réforme de
la police nationale
on essaye d'être honnête
pardon de cette de cette phrase de la
présentation nationale mais pour faire
baisser chiffre d'affin c'est pas très
compliqué vous dites au commissaire de
police à partir de d'octobre vous
n'enregistrez plus les les dossiers
comme ça vous comptez en 10e en 9e de et
puis après vous dites bah ça c'est pour
janvier prochain
eu des problèmes parce qu'après les gens
voient que c'est un problème bon nous on
essaye de dire au moment où la plainte
est déposée on l'enregistre comme étant
la plainte du jour premièrement donc on
ne triche pas sur les stops deuxièmement
la difficulté que nous avons elle est
importante c'est que nous avons une
multiplicité désormais de contentieux et
bien sûr les violences conjugales ont
complètement changé la façon de
fonctionner la police et de la
gendarmerie puisque nous avons dit
armées ici au gendarmes non seulement
vous ne prenez plus aucune main courante
mais vous déposez tout en plainte ou en
ouverture si c'est un signalement pour
que le procureur de la République puisse
faire évidemment une poursuite et par
ailleurs vous vous concentrez sur les
plaintes physiques les plantes qui
touchent les personnes et on verra les
plaintes des biens plus tard je
caricatures mais c'est grosso modo
j'avais qu'à comprendre que il vaut
mieux s'occuper des personnes que des
biens quand on doit faire deux urgences
du coup les stocks c'est surtout des
stocks de bien ça peut être aussi des
stocks de personnes mais des plantes
contre ces gens qu'on retrouve pas donc
le premier sujet c'est un peu on a été
un peu structurellement il y a des
stocks dans la police nationale par
manque de PJ par une grosse délinquance
qui existe deuxièmement ça a été aggravé
par le fait qu'on leur a dit aux
priorise les violences personnes et
notamment les violences conjugales sur
lequel à chaque fois je répète quand
même c'est quasiment systématiquement la
mise en garde à vue de la personne qui
est accusée quasiment systématiquement
la saisie des arbres et les
perquisitions des enquêtes de voisinage
et psychologiques donc désormais pour
400 000 interventions par an c'est le
chiffre de l'année 2022 par exemple pour
les violences conjugales ça a créé voilà
beaucoup d'espaces de police judiciaire
et c'est normal pour pour ces personnes
troisièmement on a mis beaucoup de monde
sur les sur la voie publique et plus
vous mettez des policiers dans la rue
alors ça c'est policiers gendarmes et
c'est aussi vrai pour les polices
municipales je prends l'exemple de
Tourcoing je me rappelle façon on va
ensemble au commissaire à Tourcoing le
la personne qui s'occupe de la du gage
il vous dira mais moi la police
municipale la même quasiment toute la
journée des gens qui font infraction
routière et il faut aussi les traiter
donc il y a les effectifs qu'on a mis en
plus sur la voie publique et quand je
rajoute des CRS et des gendarmes mobiles
comme c'est le cas de 11 escadron
aujourd'hui qui font de la sécurisation
de lutte contre les quartiers dans les
quartiers des visites contre la drogue
etc vous faites plus de dossiers et
quand en plus les maires augmentent le
nombre de policiers municipaux ce matin
tôt j'étais à Saint-Denis il y a
désormais quasiment une centaine de
policiers municipales à Saint-Denis ils
apportent au commissariat des enquêtes
supplémentaires donc les effectifs en
plus de tout le monde apportent des
enquête et puis quatrièmement chacun a
vu aussi qui a une politique de priorité
du parquet qui correspond plus ou moins
à je poursuis je ne poursuis pas et je
pense qu'il faut qu'on soit cohérent
aussi on peut pas dire aux gens vous
devez aux policiers vous devez
absolument prendre la plainte et vous
pouvez pas juger de l'opportunité de la
plainte ça quelqu'un a le droit de poser
une plainte en France même s'il paraît
farfelu et il faut que le parquet la
contrepartie de ça c'est qui clôture
assez vite des plates farfelues et c'est
pas toujours le cas par manque de moyens
par mois donc vous avez voté un texte
celui du garde des sceaux et il y a la
dernière me semble-t-il qu'il prenait
justement que d'un certain temps de
vacuité on mettait fin assez voilà donc
c'est déjà ça bah oui c'est 2 ans enfin
c'est déjà ça c'est-à-dire que les
stocks vont se résorber peu à peu et moi
je voudrais dire et merci de l'avoir dit
de leur rapporteur parce que c'est
parfois un nœud cordial de la réforme
les policiers d'API ont peur que on les
utilise justement pour faire ces stocks
mais mais ce n'est un pas le but de la
réforme et deux ça existe déjà c'est que
les procureurs de la République la
direction générale la police nationale
fait déjà ça pas besoin de la réforme
pour faire ça il nous arrive parfois de
dire à des agents de PJ parce qu'il y a
moins d'activité si ou parce que il y a
plus de difficultés là vous avez en tel
commissariat puis vous les aider à faire
des enquêtes donc on fait déjà des
audiences foraines si j'ose dire voilà
et ça n'a rien à voir avec la fin de la
police nationale non on utilisera pas
des policiers de PJ qui font du grand
banditisme pour faire des violences
conjugales je le répète parce que c'est
un argument que j'ai souvent entendu
mais c'est vrai que le mieux pour être
plus efficace c'est sans doute que nous
cordonnions mieux et qui procureur de la
République
si Monsieur le Ministre alors de demande
d'intervention monsieur Denis et puis
monsieur Marc Philippe de Brest merci ce
Président nous sommes tous d'accord
c'est le ministre pour une réforme de la
police nationale elle est nécessaire ce
préjudrait forme à prévoit regrouper la
police judiciaire
héritière des maisons et la cité
publique en une seule entité la filière
investigation vous allez répondre
partiellement d'ailleurs les syndicats
expriment leur inquiétude quant à la
perte de leur autonomie financière et un
risque d'affaiblissement de leur
capacité à traiter aussi bien l'eau du
spectre de la criminalité que la
délicence du quotidien pouvez-vous nous
rassurer vous étiez en partie mais sur
ce sujet parce que les syndicats sont
très inquiets à ce sujet là
merci Monsieur Marc Philippe de Bresse
c'est le Ministre oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre en fait
quand on a travaillé ces questions et on
les l'a fait en étroite concertation
avec nos deux rapporteurs Jérôme Durand
et Nadine beluro on a abouti une scène
ce ministre à un texte d'amendement que
vous avez accepté vous avez d'ailleurs
fait plus que l'accepter puisque vous
avez dit que vous vous inscriviez dans
la logique de tout cela et on a eu trois
sujets de question le premier me
semble-t-il aujourd'hui et vraiment les
plus un sujet d'inquiétude les premières
inquiétudes c'était sur la question de
l'autorité fonctionnelle et d'autorité
hiérarchique vous venez d'en parler j'y
reviens pas et je pense que tout le
monde a bien compris que l'autorité
fonctionnelle des magistrats exercées
qu'ils avaient toute liberté et que
votre réforme n'allait pas changer quoi
que ce soit sur ce principe même de
droit constitutionnel le deuxième sujet
c'était la gouvernance
et sur la gouvernance nous on avait
assisté sur le fait que le maillage
territorial devait être maintenu la
cartographie actuelle devait être
maintenue mais que il fallait donner les
moyens s'agissant de la police
judiciaire d'une gouvernance avec des
moyens propres et notamment on avait
mentionné l'échelonale c'est pour ça que
comme vous moi je pense j'ai lu le
rapport des deux inspections je pense
que sur tous les sujets qui se posent y
compris les questions de dépaysement
c'est l'échelonce Donald qui est le
mieux adapté en tout cas nous des
auditions qu'on avait faites avec toute
une série de personnes qui ont à faire
avec cette réforme c'est les choses
zones qui me semble important de
maintenir et de garantir je réponds
directement à l'interpellation de Danny
Wade de garantir des moyens propres
financiers et humain le troisième sujet
c'est sujet qui a évoqué Nadine bellura
c'est-à-dire le sujet du numérique et de
l'immobilier je reviens pas sur le
numérique vous en avez parlé je suis
assez d'accord avec vous naturellement
il y a un problème numérique au
ministère de l'Intérieur qu'il n'existe
pas dans d'autres dans d'autres
ministères mais moi je reviens sur
l'immobilier monsieur le ministre je
reviens sur l'immobilier à l'évidence si
vous voulez aller au bout de l'ambition
de votre réforme et d'indine l'a dit
d'une autre manière vous allez devoir
revoir complètement la gestion
immobilière de toute de tout le parc que
vous avez en charge c'est pas on en a
parlé quand vous êtes venus dans les
départements c'est pas qu'un problème de
de caserne de gendarmerie ou de Foncière
Logement pour construire des nouveaux
logements c'est un problème
d'optimisation d'un parc immobilier très
important sur l'ensemble des moyens du
ressort du ministère de l'Intérieur et
pas seulement de la police et il y a une
nécessité à l'évidence de moi je pense
que vous devriez un moment
confier une mission soit dans une
inspection générale soit des
parlementaires pour travailler sur
l'immobilier du ministère de l'Intérieur
voilà donc ce je le dis au passage c'est
un le sujet qui
a été souvent soulevé par les mini
successifs de l'Intérieur
en toute bonne foi mais qui n'a jamais
été résolu et comme on va aller à toute
allure vers de nouvelles formes de
délinquance il est plus que temps de le
prendre en main en tout cas merci
d'avoir tenu vos engagements et les
établir évidemment il y a l'évaluation
et là on continue en attendant que vous
mettiez en place la réforme en plusieurs
phases mais il faudra évaluer chaque
année pour vérifier que les objectifs
sont bien adéquation avec les les moyens
mis sont bien en adéquation que les
objectifs et danser
merci pas d'autres questions à Monsieur
le Ministre merci la question que pardon
peut-être madame merci
pardon d'avoir interrompu votre réponse
monsieur ministre je voudrais vous poser
une question extrêmement pratique j'ai
pu faire vendredi soir à
Chalon-sur-Saône la tournée avec la BAC
je suis montée dans une voiture qui
avait l'air très très bien mais à côté
il y avait une autre voiture de la BAC
qui était tout abîmée pleine de rayures
un peu comme la mienne si vous voulez
parce que moi je vise pas bien pour
rentrer dans mon garage alors j'ai donc
demandé au commissaire qui était là mais
comment se fait-il que cette voiture ne
soit pas réparée parce que ça leur fait
un peu une voiture de moi qui en a une
autre qui avait été cabossée qui n'a pas
pu non plus être réparée alors il m'a
expliqué que en fait l'état n'ayant pas
d'assureur il n'avait pas les moyens de
faire réparer cette voiture donc j'étais
un peu surprise alors je vous livre
comme ça ma réflexion parce que on est
là aussi pour remporter ces questions
pratiques et une autre était que ces
gens avec lesquels je tournais en fait
assurer 5 week-end sur 6 par rapport à
leurs collègues par exemple de Besançon
qui eux ne font que
américaine sur deux donc j'étais un peu
stupéfaite parce que c'est même pire que
pour nous en médecine un 5 week-end sur
6 ça fait beaucoup pour la vie de
famille c'est un petit peu ennuyeux et
il manque juste il manquait 6 a dit
personne dans ce service pour qu'ils
aient des moyens de travailler qui sont
un peu plus humains donc je leur ai
promis que je remontais ces questions je
tape très haut monsieur le ministre mais
je pense que c'est bien de remonter le
terrain de temps en temps
alors d'abord la question de Monsieur
Wade donc je pense que c'est une
question très importante parce que bon
la décentralisation financière je pense
que j'ai évoqué sa première fois que je
dis d'ailleurs que je suis tout à fait
prêt à étudier le fait qu'évidemment les
services de PJ tel qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui existons demain et une
décentralisation notamment de leur
crédit pour leur frais de mission etc il
y a une peur que tout soit centralisée
technocratisé s'il vient pas le cas j'en
parlerai que dans son syndicale et je
dirais au Parlement évidemment ce que je
compte faire
sur le haut du spectre bon c'est quoi
c'est qu'en gros on se dit des policiers
très spécialisés comme le sont les
policiers de PJ alors qui font des
choses extrêmement complexes extrêmement
efficace ils ont peur d'être utilisés à
d'autres choses que ce pourquoi ils sont
utilisés pourquoi parce qu'il y a une
grande idée dans la dans la contestation
c'est à dire de la réforme et un peu
dans la préjudiciaire que la police
judiciaire intéresse peu les ministres
de l'Intérieur et intéresse peu les
politiques parce que les grandes
affaires elles sont au long cours et
donc l'idée générale qui est véhiculée
c'est de dire le ministre lui ce qui
l'intéresse parce qu'il interrogé par
les parlementaires c'est ici et
maintenant le point de deal à
Chalon-sur-Saône les vols l'étalage à
Tourcoing et les violences conjugales à
Lens
et les grands criminels ceux qui ont met
trois à quatre ans pour les confondre
ceux qui se sont enfuis dans un pays
étranger ceux qui demandent une
coopération cela c'est pas dans le temps
du ministre et souvent vous interpellez
les gens que des affaires qui a 3-4 ans
quand vous n'étiez pas et comme les
mises à l'intérieur en général dure en
moyenne un an bon il y en a qui résiste
un peu au choc mais mais voilà donc du
coup si tous les moyens sont donnés dans
une direction unique de la police
nationale le ministre va avoir envie
pour avoir des résultats politiques
poussés par la pression de pignon public
de laisser tomber le haut du spectre
pour s'intéresser à la vie quotidienne
et vous concitoyens il vous interroge
sur la vie quotidienne il vous interroge
pas sur sur le commandant d'Archos même
si évidemment c'est c'était c'est un
point un point très important et
évidemment si on veut lutter
profondément pour les trafic de stupe il
faut s'attaquer plutôt à Marcos que à la
vie à la vie quotidienne bon moi je
pense que c'est une critique qui n'est
pas bien fondée parce que ça voudrait
dire que byza Tyler n'a aucune
conscience de l'intérêt général elle ne
voudrait faire que de la politique ici
maintenant bon alors imaginons que ce
soit le cas naturel des hommes et des
femmes politiques
je veux ici redire que non seulement les
offices parce que dans le haut du
spectre les policiers de police
judiciaire très spécialisés sont dans
des offices très souvent ne sont pas
bousculer on les supprime pas on les
diminue pas au contraire on va les
renforcer donc ces offices continueront
par exemple le cliff pour la brigade
financière on a souvent dit aussi que
cette réforme c'était pour retirer des
moyens la brigade financière pour
pouvoir moi s'intéresser aux politiques
aux chefs d'entreprise et ok plutôt
s'intéresser à autre chose c'est pas le
cas puisque on ne touche pas les offices
on va même renforcer leurs effectifs bon
donc c'est une fausse une fausse
information et puis encore une fois ce
n'est pas le minisateur qui saisit
l'office pour une affaire c'est bien les
magistrats qui choisissent est-ce que
c'est commissaire de Tourcoing ou
l'office qui enquête sur tel ou telle
question
ce que je peux dire cependant c'est que
il faut aussi que les je crois que
beaucoup de gens n'a pas judiciaire a
compris comprendre que le point de deal
à Tourcoing il est désormais souvent
relié à un trafic international qui
utilise souvent aussi les nouvelles
technologies je pense que en crochets
pour parler de deux sujets police
nationale gendarmerie ont démontré que
les assassinats ciblés des actes de
torture la des points de Deal dans des
petits coins de France était tous reliés
à une vision tentaculaire des choses et
donc il faut pas le travail de la police
et de gendarmerie il est il risque
d'être assez inutile si on traitement
les points c'est la petite délinquance
et puis aller grande délinquance qui
sont les grands noms en fait les grandes
délinquance passer les grossistes et
puis après il y a les il y a les détails
voilà et tout ça malheureusement c'est
un fil et et je dis pas que les grands
offices et les policiers de la police
judiciaire très spécialisée doivent
s'occuper du produit de Tourcoing je dis
que l'information fait par la Sûreté
urbaine de l'île doit remonter
évidemment beaucoup plus naturellement
dans dans chez les grands enquêteurs je
mets évidemment des guillemets parce que
cette information leur permet de pouvoir
être plus efficace et puis troisième
sujet ça je pense que c'est un point
c'est un point très important il faut
bien comprendre pourquoi on fait ce
genre très fort moi il m'est arrivé de
constater depuis deux ans et demi
maintenant que je suis mise à
l'intérieur que il y a des affaires
qu'on fait pas ou qu'on fait mal ou
qu'on fait trop tard ou qu'on fait bien
après parce qu'on n'a pas assez
d'effectif de police pour faire les
perquisitions vous savez qu'on fait des
grandes affaires de drogue ou des
grandes affaires
judiciaires vous avez besoin quand vous
faites 10 perquisitions en même temps
dans 10 endroits différents de beaucoup
de policiers de beaucoup de policiers
vous avez besoin d'enquêteurs vous avez
besoin de policiers ces usure de voie
publique pour barrer les rues pour
regarder les sorties et donc il y a des
commissariats il y a des antennes de
police donc comme il y a pas assez de
policiers de police judiciaire on fait
un calendrier si j'ose dire de dire
quand le magistram donne le goût parce
que magistrat donne le logo parfois la
veille pour le lendemain c'est pas si
évident que ça ou quand on va apprendre
à go fast ou et on doit mobiliser 15 20
30 40 50 60 parfois 100 agents de police
nationale et on les a pas sur la
préjudiciaire donc du coup en retard
alors que là l'idée c'est de dire que le
directeur qui sera au courant de ça il
dira on arrête tout demain on fait pas
l'opération de sécurisation du métro de
Tourcoing qu'on avait prévu vous voyez
on a trouvé beaucoup plus important et
on contribue au 15 interpellations en
même temps pour avoir l'épreuve et aucun
sperquisition en même temps on retarde
pas l'affaire en attendant que tous les
policiers de la pjdille évidemment je
caricature des propos c'est que vous
compreniez voilà et donc on sera aussi
plus efficace parce que
si je veux dire c'est la sécurité
publique il doit avoir un petit peu peur
de cette réforme parce que c'est pas
contrairement à ce que pense la PJ la PJ
qui sera omnie au service de sécurité
publique mais l'inverse c'est les agents
de sécurité publique qui sont beaucoup
plus nombreux qui seront plus utilisés
par la PJ pour faire des interpellations
et ça laisse au policiers du spectre les
grandes affaires mais ils utilisent les
policiers qui ne sont pas des policiers
de spécialisés de préjudiciaire
concourir à la faire parce que pour
faire des perquises vous avez pas besoin
d'avoir toujours des policiers du du
spectre je t'emmènerai par dire et ça
c'est un point très important
qu'aujourd'hui les sûretés
départementales et les commissariats
font des affaires qui étaient ceux de la
préjudiciaire il y a 15 20 ans moi on
arrive de dire des fiches ou la police
la police nationale telle commissariat
fait 30 40 50 200 300 kg de drogue ça
arrive et c'est une sorte départementale
qui le fait ou qui interprètent un type
qui a fait trois meurtres il y a 20 ans
c'était pas comme ça c'était très rare
que quelqu'un fasse plusieurs dizaines
de kilos de cannabis dans une cité
maintenant j'ai pas que c'est quotidien
mais quasiment et c'est la vie de l'EPJ
du commissariat et je pense que la
préjudiciaire doit aussi comprendre ça
qu'il y a eu une sorte de montée en
gamme très importante des EPG de
commissariat du fait notamment la
circulation de la drogue et de la
délinquance qu'il est qu'il épouse
aujourd'hui à faire des affaires très
importantes et parfois ça va faire très
important bah il y a pas de grosse
condamnation pénale parce que le PJ euh
bah il est peut-être devant une affaire
un peu trop grosse peut-être pas assez
formé peut-être pas assez spécialisé
puis on a chopé le gars on n'a pas chopé
le ramification parce que les gens se
parlent pas assez entre l'eau et le bas
bon pour résumer oui le du spectre
s'occupera du spectre on va pas les
utiliser voilà quand vous avez la chance
d'avoir de grands artistes vous les
voulez vous les pas évidemment à faire à
faire autre chose
bien sûr dans la semaine sur la question
de Monsieur de Bresse bon je pense qu'il
vous avez raison sur la justice on a
beaucoup rassuré je crois que d'ailleurs
plus magistrats disent aujourd'hui
séparation des pouvoirs autorités
judiciaires autorité fonctionnelles je
pense que dans la compromis cartographie
c'est sans doute un point encore
négociation qu'on peut avoir c'est à
dire qu'on voit bien que ce qui gêne une
grande partie de la BJ moi j'entends ce
que disent ceux qui conteste dire bah
voilà la Direction Départementale la
police nationale pour nous ça va pas
dans certains départements parce que
c'est trop petit alors j'ai toujours eu
dit que c'était ma vocation régionale
raisonnable mais les manifestement je
m'exprime mal ou je suis malentendu on
n'a pas tout à fait donc ce que je vais
proposer peut-être en m'inspirant de des
rapports à la fois du ministère du Sénat
et l'Assemblée c'est que je proposais
aux organisations syndicales de faire
des propositions de modification voilà
s'il pense qu'il y a un périmètre de PJ
qui peut être légèrement différent que
ce qu'on a imaginé mais regardons-le et
c'est pas peut-être vrai partout c'est
peut-être pas vrai autant dans le
Finistère que dans le Nord que dans la
Creuse qu'à Marseille voilà donc je suis
encore ouvert bien évidemment la
discussion et les associations
syndicales je crois sont les bons
interlocuteurs après l'inspiration que
vous portez des parlementaires pour
changer sans doute un centre de choses
pour assurer la police judiciaire je
reviens pas sur le numérique parce que
je suis en train de payer la dette
numérique précédente donc j'espère que
je la rende je rendrai ça sans je serai
pas de difficile et je raisonne la dette
numérique donc j'espère que je partirai
en une résorbé cette dette numérique sur
l'immobilier vous avez raison mais en
général ça pose la question de comment
on doit accueillir les gens dans les
commissariats les brigades de
gendarmerie 21e siècle c'est pas
simplement les locaux fonctionnels je
pense que ça pose la réalité la question
alors pourquoi Mélissa à l'intérieur on
pose toujours la question il répond pas
d'abord devant l'immensité du parc
immobilier nous avons des implantations
partout et de toutes formes
d'implantation c'est-à-dire que je suis
sans doute à la tête du ministère qui a
les importations les plus diverses entre
la place Bovo ce hôtel particulier
magnifique jusqu'au commissaire de
Tourcoing en passant par la
sous-préfecture
d'aventurep qui passe même par une
brigade de gendarmerie ou une caserne où
on a mis des escadron mobile qui sont en
outre-mer on en a partout de toutes
sortes de tout âge avec des montages
très compliqués parfois c'est les
collectivités qui l'ont montées parfois
cet un partenariat parfois ça bailleur
social parfois c'est l'état parfois
c'est l'État qui vit dans un bâtiment
qui l'entretient alors que cette
département les préfectures en étant à
bel exemple donc en fait on a une
immensité diversité de patrimoine on
sait déjà pas bien et c'est pas à vous
que je vais la prendre monsieur le
ministre gérer patrimo le public alors
en plus dans un ministère qui est pas
spécialisé pour ça avec autant de
d'administration si l'eau qui ont été
rajoutés le ministère de la défense
quand il est venu Miss un intérieur bref
avec beaucoup de réformes on est un peu
quoi devant l'énorme parc que l'on doit
que l'on doit gérer donc moi je crois
encore une fois on a dit dans la dans la
lottomie la foncière me paraît une bonne
idée la foncière en tournée c'est on
garde la majorité on garde la puissance
mais on fait rentrer des gens donc c'est
le métier parce que c'est le métier de
gérer l'immobilier c'est pas toujours le
métier du ministère de l'Intérieur
encore une fois les commissions de
police sont formidables mais gérer
l'immobilier je pense que c'est un
métier on devrait peut-être s'inspirer
de ça dans l'état et pourquoi pas je
prends note de la mission en tout cas
c'est sûr que c'est un sujet très
important on a un double problème oui ça
va d'ailleurs on a nos réforme qui doit
s'adapter à notre immobilier bien sûr et
puis la transition énergétique de nos
bâtiments
mériterait à mon avis beaucoup de
littérature mais on n'a pas alors pour
terminer sur votre interpellation vous
avez parfaitement raison
alors je ne connais pas exactement la
situation de Chalon mais je vais promène
m'y intéresser des soirs je fais
pourtant beaucoup de visites de
commissariat de brigade de gendarmerie
l'état ils sont propres assureur mais ça
c'est normal mais comme une collectivité
enfin j'étais mon propre assureur quand
si j'ose dire à la mairie de Tourcoing
c'est plutôt un bon un bon point notre
difficulté c'était il est de trois
ordres le premier on l'a résolu c'est
qu'il y avait une énorme vétusté du
matériel et notamment des véhicules on a
changé trois véhicules sur 4 dans la
police nationale en deux ans et demi
plan de relance
compris donc vraiment on a fait une
révolution dans la police nationale
gendarmerie je pense que ça se voit et
qu'ils en sont contents
[Musique]
il se peut que
la BAC par nature son travail c'est
d'aller arrêter les voleurs donc parfois
il risque les voitures vous en revanche
c'est pas votre métier si je peux me
parler de vous auriez faire attention
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la bague
c'est normal qui l'envoie dur en prenne
un couple parce que c'est leur métier de
tous les jours bon on essaie d'ailleurs
de leur acheter des véhicules qui qui
leur va pour faire ce métier spécifique
notre problème c'est
[Musique]
la chaîne administrative pour réparer
ces voitures et en fait pour réparer les
voitures on les envoie au gaming donc au
garage voilà qui dépend du préfet de la
zone de défense le problème et c'est
pour ça qu'il manque des carrossiers
c'est que nous avons dans la vie
publique état ce que vous avez dans vos
collectivités locales on a du mal à
faire venir des artisans pour travailler
en tant que fonctionnaire en tant
qu'ouvrier d'État parce que il trouve
dans le privé puisqu'il y a pas cet
artisan pour le faire c'est un métier en
tension c'est le monsieur le Président
et il trouve dans le il trouve dans le
il trouve il trouve évident dans le
privé des gens qui dépaillent bien plus
que ne la fonction publique qu'elle soit
territoriale ou d'état donc c'est très
compliqué moi je on fait de
l'apprentissage avec des carrossiers
avec on en a pas assez des garagiste
voilà donc du coup deuxième solution
soit vous attendez pendant des jours et
des jours et des jours la réparation bon
plus le fait que l'État a tendance à
acheter
le matériel au moment où la voiture a un
problème et pas avoir de stock ce qui
était un problème parce que du coup on
perd du temps pour avoir le matériel
quand la voiture a un problème c'est un
autre sujet de gestion des données
publiques avec lequel je me bats merci
on essaie du coup de travailler et c'est
ce que j'encourage les préférés des
commissaires à faire avec les garagistes
locaux il vaut mieux avoir un bon accord
avec le garagiste local ou avec le
Centre municipal de le garage municipal
de la ville pour pour faire un symptôme
de petits changements donc je vais
regarder il y a un truc qui va pas
manifestement parce que cette voiture
elle aurait dû être évidemment quand on
n'a pas les possibilités en interne on
les fait en externe et moi j'encourage
cette décentralisation et ça fait vivre
nos commerçants sur les horaires bon
les horaires ce que vous dites j'entends
mais il faudrait que je regarde plus
plus sérieusement pourquoi parce que
c'est pas normal de faire quatre
weekends sur 5 et maintenant c'est
normalement un week-end sur deux
pourquoi parce que j'ai engagé la fin
d'un symptôme de cycle consommateur on
va dire pour les pour les forces de
l'ordre oui il faudrait qu'il y ait plus
il faut qu'il y ait plus de monde doit
faire ses cycles de weekend sur deux
mais pour qu'ils puissent de monde il
faut aussi que les policiers soient
volontaires travailler la nuit si moi je
ne peux pas forcer les policiers de lui
donc en fait vous allez dû rencontrer
des policiers de nuit des gens très très
courageux mais peut-être que c'est un
petit sujet aussi au sein même du
commissariat c'est à dire que ceux de la
nuit bah ils ont pas toujours les mêmes
horaires et les mêmes envies que ceux du
jour et que c'est pas toujours un
problème d'effectif c'est aussi un
problème de répartition des effectifs
dans l'emploi horaire et quand moi
j'affe des policiers dans un
commissariat j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
vous dire que je pouvais prendre
affecter directement j'étais obligé
d'ouvrir des postes je reviens pas sur
cette question imaginons qu'ils viennent
au commissariat de Chalon je ne peux pas
les forcer ni moi ni DDSP aller faire
travailler la nuit donc
et Sacha qui se parle à la queue parce
que moi il y a des effectif la nuit bah
moi on peut changer les horaires donc on
travaille toujours avec les mêmes
personnes et donc du coup donc je vais
regarder Chalon bien évidemment mais
l'année qui vient c'est une année les
derniers à le faire c'est quasiment
préfecture de police ou le renforcement
général des effectifs permet de faire un
cycle horaire qu'on appelle le binaire
mais voilà exactement qui leur permet
alors en général les policiers d'années
ils aiment pas trop ça au début pourquoi
parce que ils avaient une habitude de
travailler pendant un certain temps
parce que faire 12 heures de suite c'est
ça le binaire faire 12 heures de suite
c'est un peu fatiguant quand on est
policier de nuit c'est pas pareil c'est
très fatiguant quand on est pressé de
jour mais c'est pas tout à fait pareil
que la nuit et par ailleurs ils ont des
habitudes de famille notamment parce
qu'ils habitent assez loin souvent en
zone gendarmerie d'ailleurs et donc du
coup il faut se taper aussi la
circulation de la sortie de vie etc donc
eux ils sont bas pas toujours très
favorables non plus à passer au binaire
mais une fois qu'ils sont face au
binaire moi je constate que ils nous
remercient parce que bon certes ils ont
changé leur vie de famille et ça c'est
un peu complexe mais ils arrivent
évidemment à quelque chose de plus je
terminerai par dire à monsieur le
président de la commission des lois je
sais qu'il est attaché sur la question
des voitures ça n'a rien avec la réforme
de police nationale mais quand même moi
je suis favorable pour que vous nous
aidiez collectivement je sais que mes
ajustices il réfléchit mais je pense
qu'on a besoin vraiment de du bon sens
du parlementaire de la Nation pour que
nous ayons davantage de véhicules
saisies à utiliser et pourquoi alors il
y a une bêtise de la part du ministère à
l'intérieur souvent il nous arrive
nous-mêmes de refuser des véhicules
saisies parce que lorsqu'ils sont les
voitures de luxe par exemple
nous ne faisons pas parce qu'on a pas de
pièces de rechange et donc
l'administration dit ah bah non comment
on appelle des échanges quand ils seront
cassés on pourra pas moi je leur dis on
s'en fiche vous la casser bah vous la
mettrais à la poubelle bon mais je pense
qu'on a un peu trop de complexité encore
à récupérer les saisies d'abord je pense
que c'est une c'est une économie pour
ministère de l'Intérieur bien évidemment
c'est aussi une forme d'appropriation de
la voiture du voleur c'est quand même
pas mal pour marquer son territoire et
le problème qu'on nous expliquait vos
amis de la BAC de Chalon que je salue
c'est qu'ils sont souvent repérés
désormais parce que c'est toujours les
trois quatre mêmes véhicules j'ai beau
échanger
tous les ans tous les deux ans la vérité
c'est que bon bah c'est soit des Ford
Mondeo enfin c'est toujours à peu près
les mêmes modèles et puis bon tout le
monde a repéré les plaques
d'immatriculation donc si on a des
véhicules de saisie ça permet de faire
des filatures et ça peut être des
interventions de plaques qui ne
connaissent pas et là vraiment je crois
qu'on a besoin de voilà d'accélération
de ce processus de saisie c'est pas une
question budgétaire c'est une question
pratique c'est le Ministre une dernière
question de la Gontrie
et puis après nous lèverons notre séance
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
une remarque sur sur le contexte et une
question sur le fond je vous écoutais
depuis tout à l'heure
et au fond j'avais l'impression un petit
peu comme sur la réforme des retraites
c'est à dire que il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes manifestées il y a des
manifestations il y a des prises de
position un petit peu
voilà qui ne sont pas qui contestent
cette réforme et j'ai l'impression que
vous expliquer qu'en fait c'est normal
quand il y a une réforme les gens sont
toujours inquiets et que vous ne prenez
pas la mesure de cette inquiétude sur le
fond
quand on regarde le rapport des trois
inspections
il qualifie leur
évaluation de de
ce qu'ils étaient censés évaluer c'était
les expérimentations avec un terme qui
est assez joli
de contraster
on va épargner le voilà en disant
[Musique]
que d'une part c'est trop récent puisque
ça a été souvent mis en place en été
2022 donc ça n'a pas permis d'obtenir
dans tous les départements les résultats
attendus cadrage insuffisant
d'expérimentation vont très bien mais
bon l'ensemble est assez on va dire
contrasté des inspection c'est pas des
c'est pas l'avant-garde de la révolution
pour les Terriens en général et il
formule 19 recommandations
et donc ma question est-ce que vous
allez suivre ces 19 recommandations
faites à la suite de l'évaluation de
l'expérimentation
c'est valable alors la réponse est oui
l'intégralité des 19 madame la sénatrice
intégralité et j'ai dit avec cette
endurance j'avais juste une
interrogation qui était sur qui s'occupe
de la probité ce que c'est le zona
est-ce que c'est enfin c'est veniel on
discutera du coup ça me permet cette
réponse rapide de vous faire une
remarque et vous soyez une différence ça
paraît que vous faisiez sur la des
contestations la remarque c'est que fort
heureusement qu'on écoute ceux qui ceux
qui ne sont pas d'accord je constaterai
que ça n'empêche quand même pas l'action
si je prends l'exemple d'une réforme que
votre gouvernement a fait lorsqu'il
était en responsabilité et que tout le
monde désormais constate que c'était ma
réforme la fusion des actions générales
des impôts la direction générale la
comptabilité publique à fenêtre je crois
des normes contestations à problèmes de
faire démissionner un ministre
d'ailleurs de votre gouvernement
aujourd'hui je pense que tout le monde
voit que tu as déjà FIP
c'est une administration qui fonctionne
bien et on a eu raison de fusionner par
exemple ces deux directions qui
travaillent en silo et qui permet
travaillent différemment donc je pense
que c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
contestations que il faut arrêter toute
réforme sinon évidemment on n'y arrive
pas et
en l'occurrence je pense que c'était mal
fondé c'est contestation à l'époque
puisque je trouve que tout le concept a
déjà fait c'était une bonne chose et je
prenais vraiment une remarque pour
montrer que évidemment chaque personne
qui essaie de transformer
peut avoir des contestations en face et
les écoutes après la grande différence
peut-être avec les formes des retraites
c'est que vous vous avez voté la loi que
j'ai proposé et que donc je me sens tous
concerné finalement par par cette
transformation chacun constate qu'il y a
à améliorer la police nationale de son
fonctionnement il y a derrière la police
nationale des femmes des hommes qui ont
mis beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de vie
personnelle beaucoup de sentiments dans
leur métier qui est un métier à une
énorme pression grosse identité et moi
je pense que l'une des raisons
principales pour lesquelles une partie
et je terminerai là-dessus
une partie des agents le conteste c'est
parce que justement ils ont peur de
perdre cette identité et qui sont
parfois une vocation d'une vie quand on
est policier d'après judiciaire c'est
vocation d'une vie on a tous sacrifié
parfois pour ça et je le comprends très
bien et mon travail et ce travail que
nous faisons ensemble c'est évidemment
les rassurer après madame
la comparaison est à la forme des
retraites me paraît étonnante sauf pour
le le
l'envie de faire de la politique
absolument parce que il y a 250 000
policiers
[Musique]
je crois que si vous les interrogez
l'immense majorité des policiers que
pour rencontrer tous les jours non
seulement ne conteste pas mais approuve
une réforme qu'ils attendent depuis très
longtemps notamment les policiers dit de
sécurité publique ce que nous
rencontrons c'est choisir lorsque nous
rentrons dans un dans un commissariat de
police
ceux qui comptait c'est une partie de la
police une partie non mais c'est une
réforme de la police nationale ce c'est
j'essaie de vous convaincre depuis tout
à l'heure c'est pas une réforme de la
police judiciaire c'est toute la police
nationale qui est concernée aujourd'hui
il y a plein de gens de la sécurité
publique qui sont aussi bousculés dans
leurs habitudes plein de gens de la PAF
qui sont bousculés dans leurs habitudes
il y a une partie qui pose un syndrome
de questions que évidemment il faut y
apporter des réponses et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que le modèle qui est
celui sur lequel nous allons aller c'est
un modèle type sur darbory national qui
fonctionne déjà aussi outils préfecture
de police qui fonctionne déjà ainsi donc
moi ma porte évidemment est toujours
ouverte j'ai un énorme respect pour y
compris ceux qui ont des opinions
divergentes sur ce que nous proposons je
crois qu'on a mis déjà beaucoup de
compromis on va entendre ce qu'on va
dire vos rapporteurs comme ceux de
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai déjà dit que
je prenais l'intégralité des
propositions des inspections y compris
ceux de la justice et surtout moi je
vais écouter désormais les relations
syndicales dans les sources syndicales
ce sont jamais exprimées jusqu'à présent
peut-être devant vous
monsieur le rapporteur madame leur
rapporteur mais pas de pas parce qu'ils
avaient pas le projet donc Nathan ils
l'ont et donc on va la demander en
fonction de ses amendements évidemment
j'en prendrai une très grande partie je
pense de ce que les premiers échanges
que j'ai pu avoir avec eux j'aurai
l'occasion de montrer que je non
seulement j'écoute mais j'entends
et bien écoutez merci monsieur le
ministre de votre présence cet
après-midi des réponses aux questions
qui ont été formulées nous allons lever
la séance merci à vous rendez-vous
demain matin à 8h30 ici on est siéon
législation en commission oui dispenser
une ministre il y a pas de souci
et puis ensuite nous irons pour 9h30
dans notre salle de commission pour
continuer voilà